i'm just thinking about i'm thinking
about a lot of stories and things that
happened you know
i remember when we were together you you
had your
amazing dogs flossy and uh templeton
and vivian yeah i remember one time we
were it was christmas
and you came up to canada to my parents
house for christmas and uh i flew
flossie up to canada for christmas and
didn't
tell you you were sitting on the floor
of the house that i grew up in as a kid
and i opened the door and flossie walked
out
and i remember you you you're looking at
flossie
and you thought oh there's a dog that
looks like flossy and then you realized
it was flossy and it was
it was it was very cute and so i i sort
of have this lifelong love of dogs now
because of uh flossie and templeton and
vivian
yeah well we had that house fire and
flossie
uh saved us and you know got us out of
the house and we're standing up on the
top of the hill
the house was in the canyons and i'm
watching the
you know telephone poles explode
and the house was a barn it was built
out of wood
wood floors walls and ceilings so it
went like an acme cartoon
it just sort of like the fire went
through the house and then it crumbled
and i was just standing there in such
shock and i was looking down and just
going okay i just hope this doesn't
ravage anybody else's homes are
like this one's gone and that's that and
you
like leaned into my ear and you started
singing
the entertainment tonight theme and it's
like
when your whole life i think the media
had assembled outside in front of the
house it was obviously a
horrible situation but it made me laugh
in that moment that everything was so
dark and scary and confusing and you
lightened it up for me you made me laugh
and i i will never forget that i hold in
the middle of what was such a terrifying
moment
there's this one little light in it and
it's you making me giggle so hard
in the middle of like this darkness came
this light and it was you
and you know we just had so many crazy
adventures
and you know in some ways having lived
such a public life
my whole life i still was in new
territory with what you were doing with
yours
you know you were bringing cameras in to
everywhere nobody was doing this
this was not not only not normal in the
funnest way but it was
unprecedented i mean you've been doing
podcasts for years before podcasts were
a thing
and now you're taking a podcast on the
road right now i've just
charlie and i we're about to go take off
on an adventure
crew we're going across the country uh
in a van
charlie and i are moving into a van next
week and we're going to go out into the
beautiful
uh emptiness of america lots of places
that people haven't been some of the
beautiful places that
people don't get to see and i'm going to
be doing my podcast out of this van
and uh you know kind of much like what
you're doing here
this burst of optimism and positivity
that you bring to tv every day you know
i kind of
wanted to do something where we went out
and celebrated
the great things about america uh right
now because there's a lot of negativity
in the world and
you know i became an american citizen
last year i don't know if i told you
that
congratulations so i i'm yeah
so and it's a better country thank you
tom
do you like my mug i do oh my god
is that me with a neck brace on oh
oh oh yeah
oh my god i oh yeah that's you with a
neck brace on yeah i
i found this i found this mug in my
garage
a couple years ago and i just kind of
kept it because i figured someday i
might be on your tv show and it'd be fun
to have a sip out of the mug
well the tables have turned now i have
the cameras on youtube
yeah yeah remember the day in new york
you you uh you were doing yoga you
sprained your neck
yeah and then chris went and made chris
made these mugs
and somehow i i kept the mug all these
years
i've kept the mug so i'm so happy to see
you and
in the words of patty smith we were just
kids
yes yes we we were we were in our 20s
and uh now now i'm not in my 20s anymore
um but where does the time go
yeah we get a lot of amazing amazing
experiences and i
i'm grateful for that and i uh i cherish
them and
thanks drew i appreciate it i i cherish
you right back
thanks drew thank you tom um
i want to mention that the tom green
interview
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts
is out it will be available i suggest
you go
through a library of tom green when
you need it most or you just want to
feel good
all right
[Music]